welcome back to cbs morning's congress
is investigating allegations of serious
security failures and deceptive
practices at twitter in response to a
whistleblower complaint to federal
authorities that complaint by peter
zatko better known as mudge he was
security lead on twitter's senior
executive team from november 2020 until
january of 2022 and last month he filed
an 84-page complaint alleging quote
extreme egregious deficiencies in
twitter security and that it makes false
misleading statements to the public
and federal regulators it being twitter
itself zacco's attorney john thai spoke
to our nicole killian about the
allegations
what he found inside this company uh was
unlike anything he'd seen elsewhere does
he still believe that
twitter users are still at risk
absolutely and that's why he reluctantly
has decided to become a whistleblower
in a statement twitter said that zacco's
complaint is quote a false narrative
that is riddled with inconsistencies and
inaccuracies the statement goes on to
say security and privacy have long been
company-wide priorities and will
continue to be nicholas thompson is ceo
of the atlantic and the former
editor-in-chief of wired and he is here
you're also quoted as i discovered this
morning in the complaint filed by the
whistleblower yes uh so what do you make
of the uh i think the most serious
allegation for the general user that the
security on twitter is lacks yeah so
there's a long detailed section of the
report of the whistleblower complaint
that says twitter gives too many people
access to user information that it
doesn't treat data properly and that is
in violation of the decree with the ftc
that dates back you know 10 years so
that's the most concerning allegation
the national security
concern that is alleged by some
lawmakers yeah what what is that concern
and are you concerned about it yes so
remember back in the summer of 2020 when
the 17 year old got access to all these
prominent twitter accounts he got elon
musk's account bill gates and started
tweeting out crypto scams now that was
weird it was it caused it actually led
to mud getting hired to fix the problems
but now imagine that it's election night
and imagine somebody gets control of a
prominent account and starts to spread
misinformation that's a real problem
imagine they say that the u.s has made
some foreign policy decision that can't
be taken back twitter is very important
to public communication if hacks are a
real risk of that sort that's a problem
that's important well and it is a real
problem back in even 2013 if you go back
it was tweeted out that there were some
explosions at the white house it sent
the dow plummeting and we've only now
you know as we've become this 24 7
society
latched on to some of these things over
and over and over again if i'm an
average user what is the biggest problem
for me in this so if you're an average
user and you believe which i am
[Laughter]
and you and you believe the complaint
and there are a lot of questions and
there's a lot to be learned and i want
to you know take some time before i
fully agree or disagree with it the
biggest concern would be that your
information on twitter is at risk both
to employees to bad actors or to hackers
that's a big deal yeah well yes except
twitter's not your bank right they have
your phone number they have your dms
there's a lot of stuff you don't want
accessed of course but it's not like
your life is going to be ruined if a 17
year old gets access to your account now
uh what's it nate's dm yeah
it depends on the person it's a fans
wanting autographs
um now twitter say that they fired zacco
for poor performance so how much of this
is i guess factual and how much of this
is a disgruntled former employee they
say he's being opportunistic and it all
dovetails with elon musk trying to claw
back trying to call back
i mean the timing is a little suspect
the timing is extremely interesting
twitter is definitely very critical of
him there are some twitter employees
who've said this guy we don't really
believe this guy there are other people
out there like this is the greatest mind
and security ever like how can you
possibly say anything bad about him so
more to learn about that but it does
dovetail with the musk case extremely
interesting ways and just gives that
soap opera a little extra spice do you
happen to know how he got the nickname
mudge i don't know i don't know either
i've been looking for it in the coverage
please find me on twitter
thank you so much we appreciate you